[Music]
writing is a great way to practice your
new language
you can submit any kind of writing on
link
a letter business report poem blog post
whatever you're working on and native
speakers will correct it for you
i want to submit some writing so i go to
the exchange page
i can input my text into the text field
at the top of the page
or click post request here for an
expanded submission page
on the post request page i can see some
of the most common words from my saved
links
i'll try to use them in my writing
when submitting i can also request an
audio recording of my text which is
often nice to have
also there are additional options for
requesting pronunciation correction
translation and transcription
all great services that can help me on
my journey to fluency
once i've written my submission and
checked the spelling i'm ready to submit
i see the amount of points suggested by
the system
i can adjust it if i like but usually i
just go with the recommended amount
i then choose to post publicly so that
all tutors can correct my post or if i
have a particular tutor that i like to
use i can choose them specifically
once i submit the tutor or tutors are
notified and when they are finished
correcting my request i receive a
correction report
in the report i can see their
corrections highlighted in green
along with any specific comments for
each correction
i can also see their general comments
most importantly i can import this
report and link all of the words and
particularly phrases that my tutor has
suggested
i can then read and listen to this
phrasing and it will help improve my
fluency
i give my tutor a rose as a thank you
or in the case of the public request i
award points to all the tutors and when
all points are awarded the request is
now closed
i typically just split the points evenly
between all characters
it can be difficult to write in a new
language but try to find the time
it's a great way to practice your output
in a low pressure environment and start
trying to activate more of that passive
vocabulary
happy linking